so I came down the next play and I was
like I'm a really sausage now I had the
triple threat I threw it all dude's face
right I was trying to go I was trying to
go easy to legs right but like a tap you
know because if you do the easy right
it's it doesn't hurt yeah people do it
like this close you know what I'm saying
you tap they're gonna be pissed off
that's when you go legs you know what
I'm saying combo but I think he thought
like I just disrespected him so he got
pissed he grabbed me he like threw me
five feet or six feet like picked me up
and threw me he wanted to like do
something worse but I'm sure he second
thoughts came in so
[Music]
oh
perfect hey what's up guys this is the
dope as usual podcast I am Thomas
dobiziola whatever you want to call me
I'm with my co-host Marty O'Neill what's
up guys guys um I'm excited we always
get stoked but uh Marty and I we're
geeked out all right you guys know from
all the episodes how stoked we are we
said this season one how sick would it
be to get him on the show so season
three coming in hot guys this is the
professor episode thank you for being
here hey thanks for having me man
humbled Superstars very excited we
talked I mean if we've had 110 episodes
and one talk oh let's go no so we didn't
want to talk about too much but one out
of every three episodes we're talking
something and one that's he he played uh
basketball in college we talked about on
the Matt Barnes episode I tried I tried
but I'm the fat I'm a full fat man
Mexican kid like just throw me the ball
try my best the game's fun at every
level though it is that's why I always
tell people I think when people talk to
me they feel like they have to be like
great to hold a combo or like for me to
think they're cool but I'm like nah like
it's fun just to shoot around yeah the
game is fun at every level so and if
everybody they could talk to you could
cross you it wouldn't be that fun for
you you've been talking with six fools
exactly no that's exactly what happened
um we just wanted to get uh straight
into it Marty and I wanted to talk about
it right after the start your social
media presence is massive you still go
hard actually
I feel like it's it's getting bigger
than it was when I first started seeing
you on YouTube I hope so
even even my my little brother's cam
says he's nine
and do you still got nine-year-olds
going nuts
worth mid 30s it's still going nuts so
you have a very good demographic of
people and I feel like that YouTube you
just I think you found that Rhythm and
algorithm like good clean fun and it's
just it's good to see well what I find
that's interesting is we've had on a lot
of different guests from a lot of
different you know sports music gaming
comedy you you know everything but
across all platforms I don't know if
pound for pound there's anybody that's
been on the show that's more consistent
with their reach and just their content
across all the different platforms it's
super it's like you just crossed over a
billion on YouTube God knows where
you're at on Tick Tock Instagram's going
crazy so you know I'm sure a lot of the
fans probably saw the M1 documentary and
you know we have a younger fan base so
they might be kind of like learning that
story for the first time but I was just
thinking like even just on the drive up
here like everybody at the end of it was
kind of left in the same
playing field in terms of what now like
we all just had this huge boost of being
on this now what's the next chapter of
life going to go for and just me being
really deep into branding and building
you know small businesses and stuff like
that like what was that transition like
what were you thinking of in terms of uh
uh like making that next step into like
am I gonna go to Nike am I going to go
to a Reebok or am I going to build my
own brand that would probably take a
long time yeah well the funny thing is
Nike and all that that was like
somewhere far off in the distance like
it wasn't happening like when and one
ended it got bought out you know by a
different entity and that's what
happened right they sold the company and
I think it went for two or three more
years after that like I think it was we
were on the day I got the cover of this
we're on the cover of the sports
illustrate the day they put it in my
hand it wasn't five minutes somebody
tapped me on the shoulder can't remember
who it was and they told me like hey the
company's just been bought out you know
what I mean and me I'm 23 so I'm like
what does that mean are we still hooping
and then somebody was like yeah you're
still hoop and I was like okay cool but
like we had no idea what that meant so
like me and Main Event we were talking
about it we're like oh I think we're in
good hands you know what I'm saying we
still got a big tour next year let's go
right so it was like it's all good but
the truth was I think they fulfilled
their production deal they deal with
ESPN and then when it ran out that was
it but the funny thing is right around
that time it's like Streetball and the
whole wave of handles and and carry
moves and or or that style of Play Just
Like went out the window like Iverson's
crossover was a carry hip-hop Fashions
uh were ruled out of the NBA right you
couldn't no longer dress like that and
one like like Iris and Ray were durag
and a big white tee all of a sudden now
cats is button-ups that's the dress
conferences and stuff everything like
flipped and like Streetball wasn't
relevant I didn't even get recognized in
in 2009 to 2000 somewhere in 2011 like
I'd go to I went to a UCLA game and one
person recognized me they came up to me
and they were like hey weren't you with
some like tournament or something like
oh hell no yeah but like that's before
social right I mean I've had social but
before before we even knew what social
was going to be before we knew how to
properly brand I had like a MySpace and
a Facebook yeah so like you back in the
day once that TV show ends or that that
acting wave like if it goes 12 months
you're out of there you know what you're
gonna remember you think think about
today we can forget somebody's own
social so
the the thought was hey
uh we've done we did overseas tours more
than we toured the U.S so when I go to
UK and Paris and Asia like people would
always rush me and they'd be like yo
Professor what's good and I would always
like try to have you know show the fans
love back thank you so much for watching
the show but a couple people would
correct me and they'd be like no we've
seen you on YouTube YouTube so I was
looking into YouTube like oh 506 I was
trying to flood YouTube because people
would rip our highlights from the ESPN
show get views on it make fan
compilations and they were going berserk
I saw a professor mix a hot sauce mix
Main Event mix there was like several of
mine they were all getting like three to
five million views some one had ten so I
was like why don't we make our own you
know what I'm saying and then the goal
was to get bookings though YouTube
AdSense didn't start till away so you're
pre-gitting people I've been on YouTube
since like oh 506 and they're not even
getting a dime but you could get a DM
back in the day on YouTube so I was
hoping for some bookings and I was
actually running out of my homies the
editor his channel so when AdSense came
about started my own channel 2009 when
you say booking what are you referring
to you know someone hits you up like hey
you want to come to Brazil and play in
this exhibition for x amount of money
yeah
yeah after and one ended I used to just
like travel the world playing one-off
either just off-branded exhibition games
or appearances or it'd be like and one
because animal was in 40 countries so
like my last and one game was in 2010 in
Angola Africa
but people wouldn't even know right it
was off the scene for years at that
point two or three years yeah 2010 I
feel like that was well passed yeah
stopped oh wait it was the last ESPN
season and so
look what back to your question what it
looks like to build a brand I'm just
like freestyling I'm like start this
YouTube up hopefully get some DMS keep
the show money going but I went
completely broke I was selling my own I
was selling my own and one jerseys on
eBay oh man I got to the point of that
it went bad it went bad to like you know
but I was living check to check I was a
kid I thought the money never we make
millions of dollars we were going crazy
so like I had a condo in La I had a
condo in Oregon where I'm from I had a
Benz I had five cell phones for hours
I'm not even trapping I got five selfies
yeah I had like three Wi-Fi bills I had
like the USB Wi-Fi chip you take with
you you were just going hard man yeah it
was different so I didn't check the
check so when it ended it it was like
what now and I was like I wasn't as well
spoken you know say I didn't want a
training to me to be a trainer I'm like
oh it's a small time and yes
so I was just trying to figure it out so
do you think if they wouldn't have sold
would the Run have kept going or was it
just the timing of it all I think it
would have kept going ESPN I found out
later didn't turn it away like they the
company just turned it away the company
tried to go like more conventional which
I can't blame them they tried to expand
right let's go back to MBA Focus
we'll still do a little bit of
everything I remember the dude when he
told me he's like hey man he's like damn
one mixtape tour
I remember that I would never forget he
was like it's just it's just a branch on
the tree you know what I'm saying it
ain't the trunk I'm saying it's just a
branch over not knowing like it actually
was the it was built off it was built
off the mixtapes and streetballs yeah
and that's how it rolls the Forefront
because it was so different it was so
different it's not College it's not the
NBA it's not high school it's own thing
so it was the only basketball thing that
really survived outside of those outside
of the Globetrotters but obviously it's
the cool Globetrotters so yeah I think
um the funny thing is they had intern PR
on and one mix it we never even had a
Hollywood the whole time the whole time
it was just so big you know you know how
it is even me now like I actually only
pay for PR like once in a blue I don't
even I don't really do it like but I get
mainstream hit-ups all the time hey
let's get it I'm saying those are ten
thousand dollar appearances if you if
you have PR and if and if those people
decide to bring you on like say like the
Ellen show right oh gosh you can pay a
10 000 rpr and Pitch you to Ella they
still gonna say like whether they want
it or not but like I get those for free
so I was like
you know let's get it but uh I was
wondering about anyway and one never got
ripped by like a CAA William Morris
background they never was going hard
went to Hollywood through the streets it
was the streets with with mainstream
coming to them but like could it have
gone long maybe we played the card right
and then Branch out in Hollywood I think
it could win I don't know that was
probably the last like organic Street
brand that they printed off 50 000
yeah no that's legendaries coming that
like Bridges the Gap from pre-internet
to into the internet you guys Kimbo
Slice anything but yeah now that was my
childhood but I can't even tell you how
many times I got called Professor like
that why do football exactly
I love that but we played up there we
played like Rochester Upstate New York
one time well and one came to Buffalo
once again you weren't you weren't there
as a side game right it was an actual
answer it was so disrespectful I felt so
horrible like it was at ECC the
Community College downtown which is like
dangerous yeah but even before the game
like the players showed up late I
remember there was just tension outside
the building before the game even
started and then we get in there and the
players came a little bit late and they
came out and one of the M1 players have
just passed away yes clay before the
Flash oh flower so this is like in the
height of anyone this is yeah oh four oh
five and they tried to have a moment of
silence for him and nobody and they were
being all ignorant like during the
moment I was so embarrassed to just be
from the town in that moment it was just
mortified me but then uh we had Paul
Harris who was a superstar at Syracuse
he was we were just talking about before
the episode like he was a part of that
LeBron Carmelo McDonald's class and uh
yeah he was playing a Syracuse he was in
the game and I remember like him going
up for a dunk and the dude from and one
pinning it against the backboard like
everybody was going insane I don't know
it is and you know I get juice right now
and it sounds so long like that's the
beauty of Streetball too is it was like
really just literally just a street
brand and everything was real there's no
script we didn't that reality show was
an actual reality show but there was
always just so much natural
but you got to see and it was the extra
layer because I remember I wasn't like
nine or ten watching like and then when
you came I'm like how much oh he's
barely older than me yeah so Juiced like
this was a kid and then we all thought
we could do it I just started dribbling
under my knee
oh we're doing that dude out there in
the snow I broke my collarbone I was out
there still with it and the sling oh I
remember all of it I was the flea market
on the tape question yeah it's the first
time you ever heard and one oh see you
know I was a fan I was a fan I was on
that end before because I literally came
on and when it right before the halfway
point you know what I'm saying which
season well you got to think so animals
started 99 you know make animal mixtape
volume nine or sorry volume one came out
in 1999 skipped to My Lou yeah that was
the first year then yeah so like I
didn't even I found out about it in 01 I
remember getting a volume two tape and
then shortly after that bought I bought
volume on eBay you know what I'm saying
tonight check that out once I saw volume
because volume one was a little hotter
volume two in my opinion so when I saw
skip at the Rucker and he was like young
and like I was already into Showtime
basketball was just naturally it's like
God's plan you know saying I was already
I tried to play like Tim Hardaway Rod
Strickland
you know Allen Iverson at that time was
like you know I'm doing that crossover
so like when and one came I'm like yo
this is it so I like that probably more
than the NBA I didn't even know it at
the time I stayed up within High School
I cultured and won remember you like you
weren't even a Hooper unless you wore
like the long shorts yeah oh yeah with
their cut off sleeves yeah with the Thai
cheese yeah yeah exactly so that yeah I
got tight I'm I have that style my
senior in high school I got Thai cheese
on this before I'm on that one so then
I go to Juco I walked on a Juco I barely
made it because I look like I'm 12 years
old I always had offensive how old were
you when you first started 18. oh dude I
was under the impression you were a
child still I thought you were like well
I looked like I was 12. that's what it
was I thought you were underage this
whole time no I I actually even played a
year Juco but I only play like two
minutes a game because like I never got
a shot at the conventional game because
like when people are like short they
don't look like like children I look
like child and I was so frail yeah but I
always had like I would cross adults up
but it was always a show like when I
played pickleball but when it got in
that season like if they let me do my
thing I'll do my thing but a lot of
times they didn't let me do anything but
they even made me think
it made me think I wasn't that good I
they made me think like the conventional
game something different like you got to
be a different you got to play with an
emotional offense yeah exactly and I
went to an all-white you know high
school and like so you got that Hoosier
the Princeton offense type Vibe they
didn't like it when I did a crossover
it's like what was that but then I
transferred to a private school uh my
senior year and I actually went crazy
because this the coach played college
ball he was more of a high level player
so I'm thinking I'm going to get college
offers I'm like oh man great like second
Team all stay I was one vote away from
MVP I'm doing six Iverson crossovers a
game and then like no college offers I
tried out for three juco's they were all
passed like oh I don't think it was all
about defense like we don't think he
could guard anybody at this level
you know what I'm saying I can't even
blame him though I look so young and I
really wasn't playing no defense okay I
was gonna say how were you playing
defense I was like Scrappy I'll rip you
if you in front of me but like at the
college game I had a little bit of like
like anxiety nervousness I didn't got to
be so unless I got off early with
offense I wasn't where I needed to be
even though I had the skills I just
didn't know nobody affirmed me to tell
you like yo you're actually super good
you just need to do XYZ like my my Juco
did it after my freshman year
I dedicated way more I went to the gym 5
a.m We got to make 500 jumpers before
class stop 2 30. 2 30 is open gym after
open gym we go lift weights and then we
come back to the gym like I'd go home or
go to the park after that at night and
now it's a street ball whatever so I'm
dedicating crazy time to the game after
my freshman year and then it didn't take
long I was like the best player in the
open gym after the season like I would
always run the court I couldn't wait to
play the next D1 recruit they bring in
to kind of like that we're supposed to
be to crash dummies next thing I know
the D1 coach is like who's this though
you know what I mean but just so
happened and when was touring I go to
try out and you know rest was history so
see I always wondered about how did you
hear because the first time I remember
what I was doing where I was standing
when I first went I actually do two yeah
I went to Footaction in Portland there
was like a mall uh Lloyd Center mall I
went to foot actually I got a mixtape
volume two I tried on the shorts and me
and my homie went back and checked it
out it was like
instant fandom culture in it like not
long after that it's like with uh it had
its own 100 basketballs basketball and
one brought a whole different level of
like uh Will Smith versus underground
rappers should I say Will Smith it's a
mainstream rapper but he's a mainstream
personality back when he was putting out
music it was hip hop basketball
that's what it always was underground
and we didn't even say it too like on
the tour like AO was Diddy oh I like
that I was Eminem Escalade was Biggie
like there was a lot of parallels there
but like honestly it was
we I don't think we even labeled it that
at the time I mean those dudes are just
playing ball like they always did and
now they're just taking on the road just
happened to be filming me so yeah like
the music was such a part of it the
music was such that the that just like
90s like beat knots Method Man Vibe or
the vines one through four was like such
a part of it yeah and shout out to the
the makers of the mixtapes you know uh
Green Point did the DVDs I'm trying to
think who did the I think it was
independent set free shout out to set
free to the music DJ you know you know
the first ones you forget do Tego wasn't
there it was it was the set he's on I am
set free on Instagram he was like set
free you know I was like yo that
remember that yeah I don't remember that
he was the announcer but he also came
with the music and and he killed it like
he got unreleased stuff stuff that he
could get rights to or whatever and like
the music well I agree the soundtrack
because it was literally it was a
hip-hop mixtape on the top of b-ball it
was actually a mixtape that's what a
name comes from it was a b-ball mixtape
yeah yeah man we
had them things on bootlegs I don't even
know when I got a DVD of it uh but I
remember it was just a piece of paper
printed right in the front at the flea
market they're like six bucks and even
backed up like six dollars I got half on
it I know we were talking about it let
me just bust this out real quick it's a
kid right here let's go young boys who
were talking about who they picked up on
this tour now correct me if I'm wrong
you then went to 20 plus cities yeah and
had to fight for your spot each night in
order to create the contract okay 35 cd2
where I came on the Second City oh damn
you come on
I know that must be at first like I made
it also yeah and like I thought I
was going if I would have went home it
was incredible like I if I you know you
got to think where my kid mine was let
me tell you how kitty I was okay it's so
funny
they asked me to go on tour that night
after that game because like the crowd
got excited but I'd go even though
hassle even shook me I touched Earth's
sick because it shook me up but like I
got some buckets and some saying I was
going back with no fear I've always been
like that on the court I forget
everything I just go in you know what I
mean so the crowd liked it I probably
had like six to eight points couple
couple of oops you know so that's like
25 as well yeah you know especially in
and one days it wasn't even about the
stat like if you had the stats it like
adds to it but like really it was just
like did you kill anyone you know I mean
and so but I was the best and at least
in Portland that night right and so they
asked me to go on tour that night but
you had to do a background check so I
missed the Oakland game I missed the LA
game but then I come on the Phoenix game
so maybe it has 32 games at 35 City Tour
and then I go back out to Phoenix and
literally
I probably played maybe 10 games and
then we get to Jackson Mississippi and
things been going well right I know in
the games it's like it's going crazy
but I was hoping when the TV show came
on that I could like press pause and
maybe just be on there maybe one of my
buckets would make it because season one
is all the team so I'm thinking it's the
joints about hot sauce and AO and Main
Event and Shane and whoever else right
so I'm thinking same thing right season
two I can't wait I'm a fan yeah so it
comes on I'm the whole episode like
literally 80 of the episode was my story
of the tryout to the game to this is
happening oh you didn't know until you
watched it they did I think I'm such a
kid they probably told me but everything
was so surreal and so fast I'm so green
it probably went in this year out the
other year and yeah so I'm sitting in a
hotel or almost like anxious like I'm
like almost nervous because first time
I'm hearing myself talk on video and I'm
like wow sound like that like that's why
I look like at the first time all the
War I remember my first time so I
understand yeah I'm like I can get new
haircuts before all this is the first
time yeah oh God yeah so I was
unadjusted to just Everything
Entertainment know anything about
demographics
nothing so I see that thing and
literally step out of the hotel
celebrity
in the hotel walk in the hotel room not
a celeb the thing comes on walk out
autographs that day wow like it's it's
actually crazy like how quick because I
see it now all the time right my cousin
he's my main editor and shooter nice oh
so you see this we go viral
he could take like when we if we go
viral today like real about not just our
videos get a mill but if we do one thing
it's like five in a week or something
like you would literally walk outside
that day and they'll be like yo I just
seen the dude they'll name the video so
it was just like that but even more
because we're all 30 to 50 times a week
um or something like that it was crazy
it was the filler show when there was
nothing on all night damn what a good
time in life that like seven year period
of it oh God it's the best I was ranting
about it the whole drive up here to
Canada oh you have no before you Donna
yeah
yeah so you walk in not a celebrity
walkout how do you adjust to this as an
18 year old kid that is literally trying
to tiptoe and walk on eggshells in this
whole event trying to make it and
hopefully you can do this and then then
you get this yeah just best I could you
know what I mean like one day at a time
but I'm loving it though you know what I
mean because I was naturally competitors
it was like all my prep I worked so hard
at the game but it was like I said
everything goes unnoticed but then when
I play pick up I'm going crazy like I'm
like I just never made sense to me
because I play against like the varsity
point guard is in my school and I feel
like
I get a one-on-one they can't beat me
but like why why am I not on the it just
never made sense you know what I'm
saying so yeah I was like AO he's like
you ain't going to college he's like
he's here you gonna play this you're
just gonna do Street my fam you're
supposed to go play D1 and I was like
you think I'm good enough to play games
I can't but like I'm searching you know
what I mean nobody's there to affirm
it's why you need mentors wow you know I
mean and I like my dad affirmed it like
my my trainer who taught me the AI cross
when I'm in fifth grade he affirmed it
but I didn't believe him they're like
family so the family always Big Ups you
right of course
so I get it it's almost like you needed
the validation once you got like I am
great
circle I'm good yeah yeah and it still
took me a year or two to like really
think like oh this is for you because
like you don't know I mean we that year
we went to Europe like I got on the team
and we did a European tour like right
then and there so we go to Europe no the
US don't even know it right stuff didn't
air for six to eight months like on the
mixtape or whatever it was always way
behind like the only the summer tour was
about three weeks two weeks delay
something like that so yeah like going
to Europe on the team it was hard I
didn't even play well like I didn't even
my head's spinning I'm like these dudes
are so fast they're going I don't even
know how to win and entertain I just I
just know how to win by default I
entertain a little bit but you know like
hot sauce and AO and headaches handles
crazy you know exactly so it's like so
turned up like they I had to learn the
Rhythm so I'm even unsure I'm like if
you don't be on the mixtape team you got
to be good Global there's a difference
between good locally and good you know
yeah nobody knows the levels of
basketball unless you play it so like
being good global probably I had to grow
into that you know me of course yeah
question before I forget I wanted to ask
you earlier what part of Oregon are you
from oh I'm from a small town Kaiser
Oregon it's the outskirt of the capital
of Salem it's called Kaiser 40 000
people got you oh yeah no that's far for
me yeah I uh in high school I moved I
got kicked out and I had to move to
Oregon because my family lived in Oregon
but Portland it's I mean for me it
sucked at the time but you know
Clackamas it's big yeah I mean Portland
for that area that's like of course you
know you know where that is I might have
that first mixtape I got it was either
at Clackamas Town Center
mall it was one of those so yeah of
course I mean I played Juco we played
Clackamas Community College oh all right
yeah we got beat by like 50. it dumped
on me you know Clackamas Community cause
he was trying to say I own two bands I
don't owe you nothing all right they
keep sending me to collections I'm like
bro I never went to your school that's
how they get I was in high school you
get money on the podcast
I never went you know on a senior day
like uh where would you like to go and I
circled it because it's the it's
one of the time yeah I never win they're
trying to tax me too bad it's hilarious
that's hilarious here's my proof but
yeah I um hour south I always like to
ask yes we did a moving out there so I
went to every little city you could
think of out there uh Hillsborough and
all these little Gresham and just see
like I was trying to tell them organs
are different
Vibe yeah way different yo you got a
basement and all that cabinet in your
bathroom is a room like you ever been to
those yeah it's kind of I mean it's
country it's like it's funny because
when we think a country we always think
of like the South or like super rural
like Idaho yeah
but it like now moving away and not
living there and go back like it's it's
country like they're very just be Forest
narrow viewpoints there's a different
vibe you know what I mean like even my
family right they they would they
wouldn't say their country but like your
country I was too like it is what it is
[Music]
hellofresh takes the hassle out of meal
time about sending you pre-portioned
ingredients with easy to cook recipes as
you may or may not know April is Earth
month and hellofresh is always committed
year round to a cleaner planet on
average hello fresh has a 31 less carbon
footprint than average meals made from
ingredients from the supermarket plus
nearly all of hellofresh packaging is
recyclable right there at the curb help
the planet while helping yourself good
food is too precious to waste hello
precious pre-portioned ingredients cut
down by at least 23 percent on waste
compared to grocery shopping which is
good for your wallet and good for the
Earth so right off the bat guys
hellofresh has saved me time and the
brain power because I am not a chef as I
once said and I don't know recipes so
hellofreshes come with the ingredients
healthy ingredients and the recipes to
help you and your family just speed up
the process and hang out together I
couldn't agree more so go to
hellofresh.com yola50 and use code Yola
50 for 50 off hello fresh plus free
shipping hellofresh is America's number
one meal kit so right now do as a flavor
take advantage of this deal right now
you can go to hellofresh.com forward
slash yola50 or just type in Yola 50 at
checkout and that's going to get you 50
off your order plus free shipping
let's pause for a moment here to talk
about something that's really been
bothering me lately inflation gas
groceries utility bills is everywhere
luckily there's one company out there
that's giving you a much needed break
it's a mint mobile as the first company
to sell premium wireless service online
only mint mobile allows you to order
from home and it passes the savings on
to you mint mobile allows you to order
from home and you save a ton with plans
starting at just 15 a month by going
online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes significant savings on to you all
mint Mobile plans come with unlimited
talk and text plus high-speed data all
of this is delivered on the nation's
largest 5G Network you can seamlessly
trans over to Mint mobile using your own
phone and you can transfer just in
minutes using esim to get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get your plans shipped directly to
your door for free go to mintmobile.com
Yola remember guys go to mitmobile.com
Yola and cut your bill down to just 15 a
month once again guys thank you for
supporting the brands that support us
so how'd they feel when the tour bus
pulled up and you're like all right I'll
see you guys later were they like
supportive it was insane how well my
parents parented me like like they fed
my dream they saw I loved it they saw I
was good at it so look
I had a trainer shout out to my trainer
Rodney Howard fifth fourth grade oh
fourth grade he showed me the first move
was the in and out then it was the in
and out crossover then it was the
Iverson crossover I pick up every move
in like a week because like all I do is
culture basketball so if I did a move by
end of the week I'd be a two thousand
five thousand ten thousand reps who
knows right you show me the AI crossover
it was like a week later crossover
adults you know what I'm saying but I'm
two feet I'm like this tall so like my
life I build trash talker vids I drop
now that's like my life I always did the
trash talker like you know what I mean
so um
they got me the trainer fourth grade
then I'm always going to basketball camp
any Clinic you can think of uh Jordans
hooping and Jordan's the hottest the
Concord 11s the original got the
originals in sixth grade I mean you name
it that my mom even drove like an hour
and a half to an AAU practice three
times a week just so I could be on an
eight because I didn't get picked up on
the big a and there's like this other
AAU team is supportive as hell they're
so supportive man and then even when and
one came up they're like yeah I mean
they're not treating you right that Juco
like we put all this and they probably
thinking about the investment I never
really asked them but think about the
hundreds of thousands spent on the game
and like now you're Pro yes you need to
go yeah we'll figure it out later have a
good one do you have any athletes in
your family uh my dad he was my dad was
like really like if my dad was probably
like fully committed the ball you'd play
college and who knows what but like no
he just he loved the game he played at
Men's leagues he taught me how to play
we're two years old at a ball in my
hands so his passion for the game wore
off oh yeah you kind of grew up into
this yeah I didn't know oh dude having a
trainer that like I said oh you know
that kid's gone he's gonna be badass you
see these kids on like Tick Tock they're
doing the basketball drills throwing the
tennis balls and catching do you see
these monsters see I wish I wish I had
something that was normal back then yeah
they had a what is it Peyton Manning cam
do you remember that if you're really
Ballin you can go to Peyton Manning camp
and then we'll show you how to throw a
ball perfectly I just went to uh
College they did the free football camp
at the local you know okay yeah yeah
yeah and I'm a fat kid I'm like all
right skins Insurance
oh damn I remember like I don't know
like football camp
it's a nightmare it's a nightmare all
the linemen like oh but yeah you
know those things go a long way though
because like
knowledge at a high level if you're a
kid is priceless right A lot of these
parents try to guide their kids and like
they do what I love the best they can
but so much bad info and bad outlooks
and you're the greatest when you're not
and you work hard when you don't really
like work hard like you need to play
college Pro you play college ball so you
know right like somebody could say I
work super hard at basketball I love it
it's like well you don't love it like
Kobe look like yeah you didn't I know he
didn't play as much as I did Growing Up
it's impossible because your parents
would be trying to get you to practice
less and get on their nerves that's what
my parents they try to make me practice
less we got beef with the neighbors
until 1am every night like you got
concrete and better than your fingertips
and it won't come out yeah
yeah so tell us now because it's beyond
just you being an internet sensation
you've developed businesses around it
yeah so what is global hoopers so Global
Hooper uh actually start I got the name
after and one ended I'm telling you like
it seem weird right now but well I lived
in L.A I walked around nobody know me
until UCLA games crazy so I looked at
Like Rappers you know Puff Daddy went to
Diddy and uh
you know titty boy went to two chains
and they Rebrand so I'm like I'm gonna
Rebrand so I was like I'm the global
Hooper so when I went on social like
with Instagram and all I was actually
Global Hooper and I was just trying to
be brand new because like why why be for
something that crashed and like I
remember I dated a girl I was dating a
girl in like 2012 2011. I remember she's
like she I had my YouTube channel I had
some old and one Clips on there right
but that time they're five or six years
old time goes by fast right you don't
think it's that old I remember she goes
this is kind of old school like a
YouTube channel
and like I see where she's coming from
right nowadays a kid I mean think about
it you two years out you might be old
school yeah oh no I get it but just to
hear it yeah yeah hit the ego
in perspective I was like is she weird
or is that the real so I remember I
asked my mentions oh excuse me yeah a
little bit oh damn so so uh so I was
like that Rebrand made sense but then
you know people connected the dots and
then like I went viral I did a
Spider-Man basketball video the first
cosplay basketball video it like segued
for a lot of Cosplay it's crazy like
yeah my homie shout out to Robert Monroe
he put me on he came with that idea
showed me how to use a DSLR and all that
it's crazy but
we made that video and then like it goes
TMZ Good Morning America you know six
million views in a week which back then
the algorithm was friendly yeah yeah
back then if you did a mill in a week he
was going off so I got ESPN CNN tnz Good
Morning America do you have any idea
who's gonna do that he he thought it was
going to go viral I was like ah because
it was you know we come from the thug
air you know the hip-hop everything
ought to be swagging and one like you
can't be a liquor uncool you know what
I'm saying so like the the Spiderman
Spiderman it was almost nerdy I was
hanging with a different crowd you know
I mean I was hanging with like my
Christian homies so like I I like I knew
it was like cool and I knew there was an
Audi he showed me there was an audience
for like Comic-Con like Comic-Con I was
like I know Spider-Man and Batman in the
movies yeah but I don't know remember
this is going way back now it's obvious
but like he put me on I was like all
right cool you know at least it'll get
some laughs if if not I gotta get a
little more views than a regular videos
because it's different
but that joint was like
I mean it was it was crazy so it kind of
opened your eyes to like a whole nother
Lane because like you said I went from
the Superstar to walking outside and I'm
like nobody noticed me and I think what
the hell it's like you said it's like a
little yeah yeah so now we're doing this
to Rebrand your whole so so what
happened was the when the block when it
hit the block or the yeah the blogs and
the big news outlets all they were
saying is the professor the global
Hoover wasn't mentioned because like my
YouTube channel started back in the days
Professor live so like YouTube was the
dominant one and you're still saying
professor and everybody's like this is
hot so I'm like why I'm a rebirth let's
go back so I went to went back to uh the
professor and then Global when I came
with my clothing brand and uh 2017 and
the name of my overall umbrella is
global Hooper so yeah it's smart you
want it to be something outside of
yourself like he has pushed trees that's
his brand it is but it's not the
professor right same idea something
bigger than yourself is that other
people the way you were going with it
with the clothes because you can't I
mean you can call it the professor
clothing like it's a merch at that point
yeah that's March which I don't think
there's anything wrong with merch it
can't go further yeah you know I've
considered going that route too because
like when a brand is actually super hard
you need a lot of investment you know I
mean so like I spent out of my own
pocket quite a bit doing that and it's
been some hot stuff you know what I'm
saying it's cool but if you want to be
in the culture you need a million dollar
investment or more you know
multi-million dollar investment to
actually be a culture like you won't be
on stockx and no known you know what I'm
saying yes oh there's nothing wrong with
merch but like yes the professor is a
super merch play so I was actually
trying to make a brand I'm like I've
been signed all the assigned like four
deals like might as well do my own now
but um I love the logo so much it's like
an homage to N1 but it's you it's so
clean thanks is there a lot I'm sure
there was a ton of back and forth about
that yeah you know I I questioned it a
few times times two on Mike is it too
similar to and one but like if you
compare them they're really not similar
yeah but like since it's a cross it's a
crossover man and it's not Jordan it's
like who was the other only other man
ever playing that day now the billion
logos yeah right it was Shaq Jordan and
Allen had the dribble man with the
swoosh that went over there and one but
I like that swoop looks like how do you
show a crossover you have to show it's a
cross which is like the swoosh but I was
like this the one when I seen it it's a
fire you know what I mean but yeah I
love that and now you just parlayed that
into your own online course too right
come I'm trying to come with the online
course soon I don't have a course right
now but I'm working on it the dribbling
class that you have oh I had it at 2015
I had was super human dribbling like we
tried to capitalize off Spider-Man
because spiders do like every video is
doing 9 10 million that one to 25
million so we're trying to capitalize so
we superhuman was the closest you can go
to superhero or Spider-Man so superhuman
dribbling oh I was thinking about
crossover five okay okay so crossover
five is just We Gather we're Gathering
leads to to launch gotcha yeah so if you
you sign up on crossover fives crossover
spelled out the number five.com you get
a free like you know five steps to the
perfect crossover and then you'll be
entered to know when I do drop then
you'll be the first to know it so it's
surprising how much that really
works and helps I had had a kickflip but
Tony Hawk I was seven we had him on the
show it's hard hey I bought your how to
do a kickflip you're gonna be like it's
those things that you remember right now
we talked about was the first time you
saw it it kind of hits you with that
yeah it's you'll remember forever it's
like YouTube is how to imagine having a
tangible how-to yeah Tony Hawks had a
kickflip was how to do an ollie how to
do a shove it I think uh like dude right
now if you if you have that and Cam
ain't never gonna forget that his life
yeah yeah you know it's like instilled
in your brain for life have you have you
liked this organic plug by the way man I
know crossover5.com you'll get a free
video five steps a perfect crossover and
we're dropping this year some point like
so yeah are you using patreon in the
same way too to kind of like teach
skills or is that not really no it's
more like a Content incentive it's funny
we just launched I'm actually debating
just going to YouTube because like it's
already built in it's hard to get people
to get off that platform and I feel like
patreon was a lot of
Comedians and podcasters yeah you guys
do patreon we did it once they were like
let's say go back to YouTube yeah so you
have the YouTube membership you have
YouTube memberships yeah yeah so I think
I think I'm gonna yeah we got less than
100 people you can reimburse you know
I'm saying we might switch so yeah it's
a lot of content just brings in more
eyeballs which in turn might get AdSense
might get there because you're fully
monetized I'm assuming on what YouTube
yeah of course oh yeah yeah okay
yeah yeah and we're we're struggling we
can't YouTube because we were explicit
yeah it's hard it's a lot of censorship
laws I think like for me doing that like
for me it's kind of like rooted in my
Christian faith I try to keep everything
if it's Christ feeling it's gonna be
family friendly you know what I'm saying
and then it just happens to be
Advertiser friendly so yeah so I like
that just happens to me I like that
smile you know what I'm saying but no I
mean you want it cool right we good good
amount of ours the person talking trash
to so many f-bombs like it's no longer
yeah so like no monetization now we we
know the workarounds and it's good now
but like yeah so I feel you it's easy to
get caught up though so I'm gonna get
caught up and I still don't have the
answer I'm like why oh yeah okay so it's
not just us so you feel it too
everybody's confused on a lot of levels
you know unless you have a YouTube rep
you can get some answers but even then
they're outsourced so like I've had
three reps I don't have one now they're
probably over me I didn't take any
advice so like
if I had one now I would though no I
think at the time we were smashing it
but like now the algorithm changed so
much a lot more difficult now like we
still do numbers but not you know there
was a season I didn't do less than two
or three mil like that went on for a few
years
now like we feel like we had a mill but
it's like a slow growth through a middle
it might take two months to get to a
mill it's a trip and then some go off
but like but then it's different it's
for everyone though I noticed the the
dip on everyone everything and I think
it has to do with like there's no
you know you wish you knew the reasons
right but I think you could say the
economy's lowers probably less
Advertiser they get money off these
memberships but I think that's why
people got to go you got to get off the
the AdSense way like AdSense is awesome
don't get me wrong I mean it's been
great for us but you don't need your own
online community that's paying per
monthly so you had a more consistent
idea of what you're going to make sure
you're not relying on YouTube we got in
a few scares you know I reinvested a lot
in my business all the time if you just
keeping it real like despite making
seven figures like sometimes you get
just scare because that bill spin a
little crazy and then the AdSense is or
it's a roller coaster you know what I
mean like one month you might for months
you might make over six figures and
you're like are we Gucci this is crazy
but then you know he's a tax return it's
had an attacks come back we now we have
a 10 000 square foot space with a studio
half court I got employees it's not
cheap you know I mean oh that's your
guys's actual space that you showed the
the layer 12 yeah Global Uber layers oh
that's you guys coming a bit I just yeah
you got to come check it yeah okay
because when I see it you shoot so much
contact because
on-site's better because then you get
audience people trash that you know what
I'm saying that's always bread and
butter but if we're gonna do a collab if
I'm gonna break down a move the
beginning of videos It's the dope it's
our offices too it's not just the court
so yeah so that's that's what before we
move into here we had a warehouse like
oh this space is what we do because on
the other end I do a lot of the weed pod
okay uh YouTube section so that's what I
do besides the podcast and we have that
like this is a podcast where we talk
about stuff we're trying to get
demonetized step into that room say
whatever you want yeah and over there's
our clothing in the warehouse so it's
like sections trying to repurpose but
all under the same like ecosystem
correct stop yeah right that's what
that's essentially what you guys just
place this right yeah 100 its own
business it's rentals too you can rent
it you know it was a little pricey but
you know yeah we got rentals for that
but yeah I feel you the AdSense you know
it's always a little it's hard man I
mean like how often a video get hemmed
up you're like what yeah it's like every
month so yeah yeah we did one quarter
rely on yeah it's hard it's hard to rely
on that's why branching out doing your
own this doing your own that own
business a question before I forget you
were playing basketball with Woody
Harrelson randomly is this a white man
can't jump too thing
it wasn't random no it was a campaign
well it was first off it was awesome big
shouts out to Woody he's like a homie I
met him 20 years ago I'm actually in the
movie Semi-Pro a lot of people don't
know that wait stop
what part you wouldn't know so we're
actually doing it it's funny I don't
even know why we're talking about this I
know you're talking about Semi-Pro I'm
actually making a video my my secret
role in a Will Ferrell movie
I'm scanning yeah it's crazy so you
would have to watch you'd have to
dissect the movie close but I actually
have like a minute of screen time you
just wouldn't know it's me because I got
a 70s wig on I box out well for the
game-winning game-winning shot I boxed
them out it feels dumb right now so you
were dressed differently yeah I would
remember this like Andre 3000 leaves our
team to go to the other team and when he
walks away it's my shower right there
like nobody knew nobody knew because you
know it's like on the mainstream like I
just started socialist tour you can't
get messages out like that well not even
that like you know I'll be like oh in
the background of uh Liar Liar for four
seconds as well Will Arnett like you
know me I'll text you see this so I'm
surprised yeah it's a premium extra you
know like there's an extra role who like
you said it's the background you're
pausing to see yourself that's called
x-rays uh I had a premium extra where
you're actually like heavy in the scene
heavy face stuff that you'll actually
say a line I'm just say I'm surprised I
missed it gotta be honest yeah so like
Woody we've met and then fast forward we
hadn't seen each other since then we
were trying to get up back in the day
the ball Dude Love is a ball he's super
cool but
this was a campaign for his new movie
Champions it's in theaters right now but
he has a basketball movie and so like
you know they just pitched it and they
were like hey do you want to do I get
deals all the time that are kind of like
weird and don't fit especially it's like
advertisement of a movie but this one
he's like hey Woody has a basketball
movie he's thinking about doing a collab
with you do you wanna I'm like
absolutely it's for what I don't care
like let's do it you know what I'm
saying we'll figure it out so we're
advertising this movie it's a YouTube
vid I think you probably saw the
Instagram little snacks or whatever but
I got to show him moves and he's like oh
I remember you from back in the day it
was crazy like he was showing a lot of
love it was dope that's legendary so
yeah because we're just talking about
this white man can't jump twos coming
out and that's why I'm like oh it's
crazy this is happening because I figure
like oh basketball but he just got two
basketball movies coming up no he's I
don't even know if he's in it though I'm
not sure about that I'm not sure
I wasn't actually a lot I was only
allowed one question outside of the
movie are you messing with me or no no I
mean his his PR oh so he was actually
cool out there could ask him anything
and we've strayed a little bit or bring
him back to the movies on film you're
only last yeah so like I thought you
meant like in first bike you can only
ask me one thing well no they were I
mean I only saw him on camera we if we
were cut it was for like five minutes
you know what I'm saying so like he came
we filmed and he left you know he's busy
he's doing a whole press run for totally
understand in Beverly Hills it's a
rented house you know what I'm saying
but
uh yeah so I was only allowed one
question away from the movie
um and I just asked me you had memorable
moments from any of his basketball
movies a white man can't jump Champion
Semi-Pro and he had this dope story from
white man can't jump so that was really
cool but yeah it's funny we should have
had the combo even my cousin he was like
you didn't even say like you're like
you're the white man can't jump in real
life like I was like you didn't even
discuss it I was like yeah I didn't know
how to say it so I mean what am I gonna
say I'm the real yeah
no that's that's insane we got to get to
a level one day we go hey when these
guys get here tell them they got a
question and a half all right that's all
they can say that's hilarious it's got
to be toy about toys or two people just
like you know what it is though like you
can make somebody look bad real easy
right you say one thing that's a little
off-kilter and next thing you know the
the whole Narrative of that shoot was
about that one thing it's not even about
the movie anymore so I I get the
Sensitivity I think there's balance
though I think they tried to button it
up super tight yeah when we got there
Woody was super cool I think it could
ask me I could ask him anything but you
know he knew it was about Champions it
was a team to have yeah for real yeah
yeah it's buttoned up dude especially at
an A-list level though think about it
like yeah he's been famous for 40 years
yeah I mean and there's levels right
like he at one point he was an A plus
star he's probably like a or b now like
look at Adam Sandler a plus Superstar so
anything you do is under the the
microscope like for me I could come out
on a video say I'm dating I did it I did
like a date video don't nobody cares it
wasn't even sorry people actually
probably didn't even believe I was
dating you know whatever like it's it's
not nobody cares nobody gives a rat's a
because I'm not like a A-list celebrity
so so you Gotta Be You got to be
protective you know
now you got to play Adam Sandler's his
favorite person on earth oh really
interesting he's a great guy you got to
play with him too right oh dude yeah and
he's like a huge fan of Miles like what
he's in the basketball heavy man yeah
like you have to respectfuls that are
good yeah
he's he's such a he's such a great guy
though like I didn't even know this you
know like I see his movie like you know
I think everybody's seen more than half
of his movies right if not I think so
every American at least man I've
definitely seen over 50 I'm not gonna
say I saw them all but I've seen over 50
and then when I met him I went back
probably watched them all but uh yeah it
hits me up out of the blue actually
sorry we had a mutual friend this one
guy uh shout out to Joe vesi he was like
an Aaron supporter back in the day and
um
we just go way back we always stayed up
but he hit me one day on Facebook
Messenger like yo uh you around this
afternoon I was like oh it was good he's
like Adam wants to talk to you and I was
like who the hell's Adam you know what
I'm saying he's like Adam Sandler and I
was like I was like the Adam Sandler
wants to talk
he's like yeah you round at two and I'm
like so I go to dude's page I said he
worked for Happy Madison
this dude was good at Joe Joe was like
real talented so he's he could work for
him you know what I mean so I'm like all
right let's get it so I'm thinking like
it's rep going to call me or it'll be
something weird right there's no way
he's gonna hit me but sure enough
the ID Adam Sandler he picked up talk
for like an hour
about basketball everything okay moving
to LA and one uh basketball he say seen
all my he said there's not one YouTube
video he missed uh he's like I watch him
late at night when I'm bored man I'm
good and uh he's and then he tells me
about hustle he's like I'm doing this
basketball movie in a couple year or two
and love to write you apart and I'm just
like what hey let's get it you know what
I'm saying I'm thinking like I was
thinking he's actually just being nice
like yeah maybe he was a supporter he's
wanting to touch base the movie was like
flow you know a lot of people Hollywood
do that right a lot of empty promises or
whatever but I didn't even care I was
like this the phone call was great like
you're dope so yeah sure enough fast
forward a year year and a half two years
or whatever they hit me and it's like
you want this roll or whatever of course
seen in New York correct that was Phil
New York it was Philly yes Philly it's
like oh there's a dope ass Court in
Philly right across from the
cheesesteaks it's like right on the
corner yeah yeah
because I was in New York I'm like is
this the same spot remember I told you
there was like a game and there was 30
fools standing outside like a cage in
New York watching this tree it reminded
me of some man once probably Fourth
Street I don't know but I was in West
Fourth just randomly walking there was a
good 100 people outside man watching
this game there was a scoreboard
New York I mean streetball's culture in
New York that's why it started there you
know he's played that like I'm from
North mid-century California right they
all look the same hot and there's a few
basketball players like that's it yeah
where you guys are from the East Coast
are where you grew up traveling I've
never seen street ball like that in my
life nobody could dunk no
that's why I'm a small town yeah we have
one dude we gotta go to a high school he
was like the man just because he dealt
once like it was a whole like a wacker
one time but you know that's but that
was A1 right and one was uh they
introduced street ball to the to the
world because that was it was Chicago
New York DC
maybe a little in Miami and land not
much I mean like Streetball wasn't
really out there like that so it's a
question because you we've talked about
this before
I I used to I told you I just study and
want to dribble my ass off and as soon
as I shake somebody I'll pass it you
score don't make me look stupid fool I
just did all that you better score you
know that was my plan like make someone
do this and I go oh yeah so I've gotten
elbowed I've gotten near fights because
on the short fat can you get shook by
the short fact you feel stupid right
though right but you get shipped with a
small white kitty like oh hell no yeah
I've got mad elbows so many fights so
many random things how have you
controlled this in your life because I
know you shake one fool that has a very
bad ego and it is a full-on fist fight
Dodge you better duck immediately and
swing because there are too embarrassing
somebody oh it's an art getting someone
one two heels like is the old you might
as well swim that's the equivalent I
feel like some people so have you dodged
this do you have any stories of of this
the first time and or how do you deal
with this man you're the youngest yeah
no um
well first off more than half the games
will be maybe 80 percent of games we
playing we getting some sort of a fight
like a verbal altered and you know it's
just because it's three ball you got no
ref right and I'm a featherweight so the
hardest thing is like everybody's just
crack they're grabbing you know what I'm
saying when you go by and that's that's
hard to deal with but like you know you
figure it out but so we're gonna get a
verbal thing over there I gotta make a
big deal out of there's no ref so I
don't say nothing they just gonna do you
know what I mean so there's that whole
thing but then
you know I think like a lot of is you
get you if you give respect you tend to
get respect so I try to do I try to
approach that Park out of love trying to
Big up everybody you know and do what I
do doesn't always go your slight smile
tells me like I mean I've shook some
fools into fights yeah so well one one
in particular was number one on ESPN it
was like 2014 or 2015. we played a team
in the CBA you know that's like China's
NBA right when NBA player goes playing
China playing the CBA okay so we played
a real CBA game a preseason we're just
like it was with ball up was a kind of
like an attempt at the second coming of
and one but like no one knew ball up so
like in China they just thought they
were playing an exhibition us team right
but we're under real real rules so play
CBA game but I like the way I play
Streetball I'd like some people say I
care like I don't really care if I have
carries or like arguable carries right
my one or two moves of blatant carry
right one one or two but like a little
pause yeah like we but I keep it I
played in the CBA game and call for no
carries you know I'm saying but I was
all Streetball so I came down and shook
a dude he slipped though slipped like
did the splits and touched Earth crowd
lost it right
before that I got in a couple buckets
and mind you again I look like Underdog
I do six four I'm my height so I'm 510
so all the momentum was our side and
when he fell it was over like now that
their home crowd rooting for us so he's
pissed right then and my you don't speak
English they don't know anyone they
don't know Streetball deuce 22 he don't
know none right so I came down the next
play and I was like I'm a really salsa
now
I had the triple threat I threw it off
dude's face right I was trying to go I
was trying to go easy to legs right but
like a tap you know because if you do
the easy right it's it doesn't hurt yeah
like this close you know what I'm saying
you tap they're gonna be pissed off
that's when you go legs you know what
I'm saying combo so I did it he moved
his head I'm like who moves their head
usually you swing at it you know what
I'm saying he dodged it he like he like
he gave like this so it hit the side of
his head and then I wasn't smooth I'm
like fumbling to get it back but I think
he thought like I just disrespected him
so he got pissed he grabbed me and he
like he like threw me five feet or six
feet like picked me up and threw me he
wanted to like do something worse but
I'm sure he second thoughts came in so
uh
both benches cleared oh it went crazy
I didn't even upload on YouTube for
another year because I didn't I just got
the footage late like somehow that
footage got leaked on a Chinese like one
of their versions of YouTube or
something like that so I found some
ripping software to rip it got it
re-edited ours because you can't speak
Chinese you can't get clearance on that
like screw it we'll figure it out later
you didn't clear it with me so I
uploaded on YouTube a year later number
one on ESPN that night oh no but oh it
was awesome but I knew the the fight
after the easy is going crazy I'm saying
so it's still on my YouTube channel I
got like 10 million views I talked about
this recently the off the face is a very
thin line of like is this gonna be a
fight yeah you normally gonna be friends
with the dude yeah maybe maybe if I know
you we gotta pick and choose your
battles and then you gotta like do it
right too like I've done it wrong I'm
not gonna lie like if I did it wrong
super like luckily it was a huge
audience in there so you gonna fight
clear like say clearing the benches or
whatever but
I don't always do it like like there's a
role there's the polite one that's the
one I show Woody I say yeah you could
roll roll because if not he gonna try
out the first time
his nose exactly I want to be
accountable so yeah you gotta pick and
choose your battles and then honestly
like I said if you go in there give him
respect and then like now we shoot we
got three angles three security guards
there's a whole crew so like you you
stepped in there you know what we're
trying to do so yeah no I get it I'm
just like referring to back in the day
it's way worse yeah back in the day I we
had some he's got real
high school kid you can't discern like
when is a good time no not at all yeah
off the foot that one was that's a
little less
a lot of room for air yeah yeah the
hardest one's got to be where you like
you're dribbling and you throw it up
over your head and pretend like you're
still dribbling eye contact and they
don't realize it's up over their head
now you know I'll be honest I did it a
couple times but I never mastered that
that was hot sauce yeah yeah that was
hot sauce genius there were certain ones
certain moves back in the day were so
signature to players you just let them
like that's their thing but we all
that's why sometimes it's a false
narrative like I stole and one player
like whether it's hot sauce or somebody
back in the desk stole their style but
it's like in that era everybody every
single player guard on the team did off
the easy off the backboard between the
legs the chance spins you know I'm
saying there was like a core of a lot of
moves but that one in particular I think
none of us could do it like maybe now I
actually want to bring it back but like
I never mastered that joint that was
crazy yeah nah what now switch it up
here just because I gotta know from back
then when you first go on tour up
through now what are you listening to
music wise oh music wise uh it's funny
because now I'm like oh gee like like
like like if you ask me like what came
out this I have no clue you know what I
mean I have no clue the same with it so
like if I listen to music it'll be from
the 80s 90s early 2000s and then like oh
he sprinkled in you know just Drake
Lil Wayne or Jay-Z drop something you
know what I mean you know little babies
the hottest in the game so you're gonna
hear that but like if I personally get
motivated I I'm like I might listen to
Michael Jackson I'm like old school you
know what I mean or like
I try listening to something that's a
little cleaner too because like you get
older I'm not even on that wave the same
wave you were when you were young so
like hardcore rap somebody might be
gonna be hyped or motivated before a
sporting event but I always want to hear
it so it might be like some r b
something like that yeah just depends
like Christian some Christian artists
like Lecrae listen so it just depends
are you super religious like very
Christian because I keep hearing it
because I heard you you say hey instead
of ask me oh maybe you might be
religious because I didn't even ask yeah
you don't smoke at all no I never smoked
my life no funny enough yeah damn out of
all your tours and all your playground
where's this where's that they'll
documentary of your life bro well this
was just on the way man just like no but
see I came to Faith in 2011 though
actually it escalates funeral believe it
or not oh wow yeah so I'm Christian but
like when you say I think you have an
outside Viewpoint I don't even I don't
think there's levels of religion well my
uh my fiance I know what you mean both
sides grandparents are pastors she grew
up next door to the church she wasn't
allowed to watch Simpsons until we
started dating type of thing so she's uh
when I say oh you're she's very
religious but yeah they they are very
religious they're six days a week at
church like so all that's when I hear
that I'm like oh my God people grow up
like this that's intense because I mean
for me it's like
like it's just this is life like it's
not even about going to church a number
you know you have a relationship with
like Christian faith really believes the
Bible is 100 the word you can have a
real relationship with God I'm I mean
I'm sold out I believe it you know what
I mean but it's more about like the it's
relational you want to be obedient to
honor God so like as far as the levels
we all are horrible we fall super short
but you know I'm making strives to be
christ-like you know what I'm saying but
like as far as like on the super it's
hard when you're raised in it because
your parents got rules based on the so
it's like you're forced it's hard to
truly find God like that the pastor's
kid that's a tough one because like
you're gonna know it all but it's like
forced on you like me I don't know
nothing about Christian I mean I think
my parents would identity they identify
as Christian you know what I mean and we
had a good upbringing they put me a
Christian preschool Christian senior you
know senior year at a private school but
like I didn't know nothing about Christ
for real other than a prayer before
dinner you you know what I mean so like
finding in my adult life it's so much
more clear than that pastors or that
Grant like I said the granddaughter of
the yeah prescriptions to make later in
life once you understand yeah well even
though you know it's more real too not
that it can't be real if you're a youth
so I know some people who came across in
their high school if they're 50 years
old now and it worked that's more rare
though you know what I'm saying it's
like you got to own it in your adult age
to make a conversation to say I'm
serious it wasn't just my family right A
lot of people are just they're in the
Faith by affiliation of family which
biblically that's not even true Faith
you know what I'm saying like if you
don't if you don't like you didn't
choose this ask for forgiveness of
Christ and proclaim a savior and really
like live that life then it's it's not
biblically not actually Christian so so
if you think about how much can you do
if you're just doing it well Mom's
Christians like the name of rude in
truth it's rooted in mom said her dad's
you know what I mean yeah okay yeah
that's what I view it though that's
really interesting I've never heard
anybody have that kind of story around
religion yeah and I think
a lot in the cursor is
there you know I'm saying they're scared
of the rejection that it comes with or
like yeah a lot of people are just
scared to be themselves in general
forget the Fate right you just people
will put a front all the time so I think
people aren't as bold they don't really
say their beliefs and there's so many
misunderstandings right like when he you
know like it's like an outsider
Viewpoint who's saying it's like I get
it because I was on that so you know
what I'm saying I viewed it like that
too I thought like oh Jesus likes Santa
right like
no I remember like no I senior year in
high school I remember I asked the dude
and he came from a Christian upbringing
and we were the Bibles class and I was
like I was like Jesus actually real you
know I asked him and he goes I think so
and I was like oh cool I guess it works
for some folks yeah that was as much as
I ever really thought into it at that
time you know okay so yeah that was the
thing like wow that that bus
must have been wild as hell yeah well I
was a Christian no no after this after
and one so no I was I'm waiting for not
smoking I didn't do drugs I was scared
of it you know what I'm saying my
parents are always like don't do drugs
you'll end up prepared to the right
thing my parents are amazing yeah the
peer pressure had to be off the chain
yeah it was and I succumb to it though
that's the thing I wasn't like holy on
the tour you know saying we had mad chat
I had two three girlfriends in every
city and every nation and everything
no I'm serious like we went crazy that's
what we always thought of like I drink
[Music]
because like when I was a freshman I
knew I was the bottom man on the totem
pole I was the freelance I was the
shortest I was the youngest I was like
did you feel like after like a short
amount of time you're walking around
with their respect or were you always
like I'm the guy that got picked up on
tour they're The Originals like I'm the
young kid did it feel like one
yeah I think like the combination of
both like
is 10 years older than I am you know
main event is even more than 10 years
old or not so like
half man was in his mid-30s when I was
18. so I felt like I was a kid with
adults yeah but it was cool because like
Escalade was like my mentor he took me
under his wing and I think he was five
years older or something like that you
know I mean but he took me under his
wing later just became my friend so I
think it started off I felt like a kid
with adults I think over time I heard
their respect and then we felt like
peers and like friends and um yeah so
it's like I got the respect but I always
did feel like I was with older cat go
hang out with my kids you know that I
grew up with they seem young because
it's like I'm with adults yeah you don't
have a car payment full timing yeah
exactly you know you're going 18 it's
like that whole like Michael Jackson
right he always felt like he never got a
childhood I don't feel that way because
I got you know I was 18 but like at the
same time it's you know thwarted into
adulthood a lot quicker and honestly
influence for the work you know like I
said we had the girlfriends we party
crazy the tour is a movie it was yeah I
mean it was
yeah it was top of the culture we're so
happy to hear it's everything I thought
yes as a kid like man I hope that this
is nuts when those cameras go up yeah
and you know it's the a lot of
learning lessons though too you know
it's like because because even in the
faith you could say like some people
Outsider might be like do you regret the
get down it's like yeah you know you
could have went going to battle things
it was pretty reckless you know I'm
saying like looking on several kids
right we Coulda
you know could have done it a lot better
but you got to learn too sometimes you
got to have a rough pass so you can like
tighten up and learn life so I learned a
lot you know I mean so I think it was it
was great what was the night like after
the MSG shot for our fans that don't
know when you come down and see Madison
Square Garden Mecca of all basketball
come down game winner half court all the
confidence in the world Place goes crazy
what's that night like
uh you're not what you you know so like
in O3 I was trying out like I didn't
hang with the players you know I maybe I
hung with hot sauce a little bit got
some combos with Escalade here AO just
want a clown all he was clowning me all
day headache and then clowning you know
I mean they're making me do the rookie
stuff
so uh what is that I probably go back go
grab a bite go to my hotel room start
calling home call my family uh I don't
even think I don't think I even hung out
none we're in New York I'll stay
somewhere in Manhattan just calling the
homies like was that like that had to
feel special like that had to be just
like a special moment in your career
would you say it is that like stand out
as the top of the top uh yeah top three
top five something like that for sure
because that that's what won me the
Contra I mean I think I had to play good
next three games
to to win the Contour our next two games
I think we went to Philly and then we
did in the hood in Linden that's where I
got my contract but that kind of like
solidified it but even if I didn't win
the comp I never thought I was supposed
to win the contract it felt like I
didn't deserve it because like
helicopter and spider two of the best
athletes I've still ever seen till this
day I mean this dude's spider was like
shorter than me he's like like a half
inch shorter than me but I mean windmill
threes any dunk you've ever seen he
could do it yeah like it's it's crazy
with athletes they don't even need to
warm up and then we playing the open run
let's give you like 12 dunks at five
nine he had 12 dunks I didn't even know
God made people there I had to like look
at the who myself and be like am I
looking at this at home maybe I can bang
you know so and then helicopter like
arguably a better dunker than him six
ones so did I think I deserved the
contract like now looking back on it
like I think my impact was greater but
they were actually better than players
they're better players you know like if
I run one
I'm getting beat yeah yeah it's not even
a debate I might get a game but not even
it would have been tough so but I think
like I had a good all-around game right
with the lobs we can shoot you know and
you're bringing people in there it's
ankles too yeah ankles is more
marketable than dunks yeah I think it
always has it was all about the
Highlight Reel really I mean yeah well
you sold and one was like skipping hot
sauce hey oh you know when volume three
came and the move the move the the dunks
are forever remarkable but the moves is
like more marketable so I think that
weighed in obviously I was white super
Underdog Eddie was just you look like a
child yeah but like if they gave it to
spider helicopter you wouldn't have been
mad at us spec man this was incredible I
lived my dream my dream was look if I
would have went home after three cities
got a couple moves and buckets still
Stokes maybe one city yeah really it was
like the year before that people don't
even know this I actually played against
that one the year before they had open
runs but they didn't do a con they
didn't do an on the bus contest it
wasn't you know what I'm saying it was
just to get people to play them so I
tried out I played against sick with it
um I'm saying I only got one move off
the whole night before yeah the year
before so and I was Superstar for a year
just off that so like you gotta think so
I never thought oh you had some
confidence well yeah I was confident
like when I played I forget about
everything I just zone out I don't have
no expectations but I know like like
helicopter spider like we're winning
this I've already played in games I
already know they already knew the
players helicopters kind of out of
nowhere he played D1 he won the dunk
contest in the D1
spider played on a whole tour with hot
sauce and Mark Mark Edwards his manager
later was minor manager but they had
familiarity they're there to win I was
there I'm like yeah I'm just happy to be
here bro is it okay it's okay if I'm not
good I'm good here so sit down right
here and do this special like that
athleticism
well special I got a question for you
about that have you ever in your career
seen a 36 year old flat-footed white
dude go from not being able to jump to
training jump training himself into
being able to do you just described
yourself I think this is possible
well you already played ball yeah I'm
trying to run a marathon right now once
I get past the marathon I want to I want
to be like in six months I'm gonna do
this drum training program that claims
that it can I think it comes down to
like so if you jump and you try to touch
the rim how close are you pretty far
like you can you touch the bottom of the
net oh yeah I'm all up in there okay so
you're mid so you're about six inches
away
you get it I think it'll be hard I think
you definitely can improve your verb you
can forever improve your vertical it's
just like the older you get the more
maintenance you have to have and it's
not just hit the weight there's so much
more to it right it's like you need
functional movement training you need to
open your hips up with mad stretching
you need a
therapy if you had past injuries you got
to give her a scar to you so it's kind
of a lot to it but could you could you
see here's the thing if you're six if
you're six inches from the rim you need
nine inches you need ten to dump yeah so
like because you gotta get your hand you
can't dunk right here like I remember
for a long time I get I get here on the
rim it wasn't until I got here I got
actually done
and that's right
later in later years I was like you know
the white guy but they weren't from
everybody everybody's body is different
too like if you're overweight who knows
that might be a game changer shed that
weight for sure you might be jumping oh
just off that and then and then you got
to gain the muscle in your legs so it's
not impossible but it's like if you told
me you were touching the rim I'd be like
oh yeah absolutely yeah no I'm not
touching the rim I got I got this one
now did you hear the breakdown yeah as
long as you get the more maintenance
Scar Tissue
those those jumper shoes remember that
when we were younger it's not bad yeah
when they thought that that was based
off a theory that it all came from your
cat yeah but the gentleman comes from
your core you know like she ever comes
from your oh jumping is is your core you
know I'm saying like some of the highest
jumpers ever gotten no calf no at
they're just they're they're slender
like me but they're like super yoked
they're they're core is crazy naturally
hard and then there's not an inch of fat
and then their their muscles are dense
so they just got Ultra that's why I
can't do backflips
watch me just stay fat I just get abs I
could do flips yeah mine was the Donk
his was the backflip off the uh portrait
we'll see we'll just get it flip is
different yeah like I'm gonna land like
terminated like helicopter you can just
do a backflip for no reason spider too
these back flipping is part of their
childhood yeah I never could do that we
we asked Matt Barnes when he was here
this was kind of shocking to us we kind
of touched on this a little bit how many
amazing basketball movies there are we
want to see if I can rattle off a couple
and see if you we can get some of your
favorites here sure He Got Game loving
basketball Above the Rim Basketball
Diaries Coach Carter white man can't
jump six man Space Jam Celtic Pride
Hoosiers hoop dreams Space Jam one so
many classical I love them you know but
you said there's a lot of great I feel
like they're all very nostalgic and we
love them for that I don't think there's
a lot of great personally I don't think
there's a lot of great movies you kind
of said that really well
yeah I still love him though I mean yeah
yeah yeah it is the Nostalgia yeah for
me it's He Got Game followed by a Love
and Basketball probably those are good
Above the Rim was always my favorite uh
Above the Rim because it was a street
ball movie you know what I mean and I
didn't even see it till I was in my 20s
funny you know I'm from a white kid from
Oregon I didn't even make it you know
I'm saying like I remember reading
something like there wasn't even barely
a marketing push behind that movie like
like white man can't jump is way bigger
in the box office but it was because
they had a way bigger marketing push
bigger Stars
which is funny now right Tupac was in
the yeah nowadays berserk you know what
I mean but I didn't see it till it was
in my 20s so I freaking loved it because
I'm like it's like I won the movie you
know but uh yeah I like to Above the Rim
and I think hoop dreams though which
hoop dream is more of a doc it's not
necessarily a movie but like as far as
the inspiration for me coming up
huge big shout out to Arthur Agee and uh
William Gates I was actually on our
podcast we became friends played against
Arthur aging like 07 in a celebrity game
wow and we were like cool so we've
always crossed paths over the years oh
that sucks but the only book I read in
middle school yeah damn near school oh
that's hard I didn't even know it was
about hoop dreams
for every book report I don't even know
it was a who carries book that's crazy
but I watched that movie more than 20
times for sure but yeah I think Above
the Rim and hoop dreams are my two
favorite but I love like I said he got
game and White Men Can't Jump I just
like the California Vibe and the 90s
gear
and uh you know Woody is a great
actresses though favorite shoe of all
time favorite shoe of all time hit me
right now I'll go old school a new
school because like the shoes have come
a long ways like they don't match up
right but like back in the day
I'm a Tai Chi you know senior year I'm
rocking I'm rocking Carter Tai Chi as
far as looks though that Jordan 11 was
special and it was a great ball when it
came out it was a hoop shoe even though
like now I can't imagine playing in it
so I'm saying I'm saying three though
for the new school though the the Kobe 5
Proto can't it's like the greatest
basketball shoe of all time I mean I'm
not gonna question you you know if it's
gonna be the greatest basketball shoe
that's coming out the Kobe 5 Proto no no
Kobe
5.2 right okay Kobe five Proto whatever
he wears them today so like they had the
Kobe 5 back in the day yeah but they
re-dropped them like in last he I think
he was still playing it came back out
with the Proto it was like the
prototypes that never made it gosh and
it was like a little bit better made
it's like a new technology some new
color it has like that that Bruce Lee
one with the black and yellow has the
Reds you've seen it everybody in NBA
wears it like right now Bruce Lee thing
really helped actually black and yellow
suit yeah like I have a hard time not
hooping in some Kobe's today just
because the the elevation of the
performance it's crazy they took notes
from soccer and then like it was a myth
you know you can't poop in low tops I
was on that myth up until
even at five years not even that long
ago so I started hooping and Kobe's very
recently the difference oh my gosh like
the fact I wasn't hooping and Kobe's
even in the last like 10 12 years kind
of crazy like such a good hoop shoe it's
unbelievable Kobe five six eights
they're all they're all like insane do
your feet hurt way more if you go play
on concrete versus playing in a gym do
you notice that it was funny I only hoop
up I very rarely hoop in an indoor gym
nowadays I have my own place you know
I'm in my half court uh I think it's the
same I'm gonna get toward 40 like if I
play I gotta chill for three days you
know what I'm saying oh really I'm
freaking beat
yeah exactly there's so much on the feet
but like it has to do with the quality
of shoes though too if I get some good
shoes I think I'll be all right like I
don't really think about my feet as much
my body's Zapped though you know I mean
yeah but I mean it's hard it's harder on
your body you play outside it helps for
me because I'm not a jumper you know I
rarely slap the backboard that's not
even in my mind you know what I'm saying
I'm doing scoops and you know I'm trying
to just break you off so I can shoot
floaters and I don't shoulder people to
the so I don't really hit the deck as
much like the ballroom I'm not diving on
it there's no grass now there's a zero
chance I'm barely playing defense I'm
trying to beat you on offense yeah
yeah I mean you gotta pick your battles
right yeah you diving on the pavement at
40s good luck yeah I already get injured
as it is like every few months so like
I'm just trying to stay healthy yeah
well man
um oh completely just based on what I
was gonna say I had the question for the
last five minutes yeah we appreciate
your fight you were fighting through
injuries just getting here hard to stay
healthy I had the Achilles 2019 Achilles
tear damn he's covered 100 though and
like I've done therapy ever since then I
never stopped doing therapy because like
if you want to play at a high level that
Achilles tear will always develop scar
tissue and it always is weaker you know
I mean so you gotta
you gotta stay on it got it for
everything just remember whatever do you
guys ever film something because you I I
you guys challenged and sometimes I just
laugh at the fools I love it when you
know when a video starting like oh he
doesn't know who this is okay this is
gonna be really great yeah did you ever
post not post something has anybody ever
just lost their mind where you just
don't pose it because I've seen some
where people get visibly upset at you oh
yeah and I've seen it and that kind of
goes back to dude one cross could get
you swung on so do you ever have
something like I'm not posting this this
is just yeah your butt hurts yeah oh uh
yeah yeah I'm sure you held up right
well the thing is we only
we don't pulse everything right I mean
we like I said it was patreon or YouTube
membership you don't get a lot you know
what I mean I think like
so yeah the answer is yes you know
because people have gotten upset or or I
was a bad sport too you know I got a
fight before you know what I'm saying I
was like ah We're not gonna go there but
I think that
one thing I learned too in this game if
you're not an MBA or college if you're
trying to Brand out as a Hooper like
YouTube I was like I'm the first YouTube
Hooper so I had to learn this as I went
but you got to think like an Entertainer
you know what I mean like you should you
should be branding the best version of
yourself you know I see a lot of YouTube
hoopers now
they put out a game that like we get
their ass busted it's like why is it on
your channel like you think Michael
Jackson approached his performance where
he slipped you know it's happened of
course and now it's on YouTube right you
can everything comes out but like
uh yeah so I think more like an
Entertainer less like a Hooper but I do
think like you need to be somewhat true
to the the real narrative right like I'm
not gonna hide like even hit like for
like losses we have losses on the
Channel I want to put up more like it's
not a bad thing I think like like for me
though like if we go on lost like we
would have bounce back with a banger the
next vid or there should be some
Redemption on that same one because
basketball you're gonna lose right Steph
Curry lose but I think like you should
always brand the best version of
yourself as long as it's not a now we've
seen a person it's like you can't even
play you know what I mean like it
shouldn't be far off from the real life
narrative because then I think it's
gonna be hard to sustain yes I'm the
best ever yeah you can't keep that up
yeah it's hard to sustain but no I mean
I will say though I say we don't love we
probably upload like 75 80 like of
everything but yeah we've had a few we
had one in particular I didn't upload
since I go out in a fight it was it was
bad too much
too much talk I would look like a bad
guy probably uh I see what you're saying
because you're cool right I mean it's
hard like I try to keep my cool every
time sometimes be so disrespectful yeah
well it's a weird situation yeah it's
like so much pressure on them on you the
cameras are wrong it is though it ain't
I can't blame them sometimes too because
it's like
they know if it doesn't go good it's you
know it's going public but also it's
funny that on the flip side of that it's
not really a big deal though like like I
got crossed up and I've actually lost
like recently I played a game in Florida
and um
easy to do you know out top off the hazy
between you know what I'm saying I went
to the red was going to go crazy it went
to rap dude I was actually gonna throw
the oop to my man over here but it
looked like I was going for delay dude
swatted that joint to the bleachers did
like two million he posted it he got it
from the homies posted it online dude
like two million views it was awesome
but like I think there's I think uh
you know it's not a bad thing it was
great like you need both sides I can't
remember exactly where I was going with
that but
no you're good you're good um so that's
that's just the question I have as
somebody that watches the content like
this has to be some my little brother's
always Johnny's always sending me the
videos I'm like yeah bro I follow too
bro I watch him don't worry because my
little brother's he he is basketball
that's all he's doing outside every day
you know I love his things the little
kid you know
you're looking in the mirror doing this
just what kids should be doing right
there yeah yeah looking in the mirror
trying to get it number one thing to
keep a kid out of trouble like yeah give
them something that they think somebody
do something with this yeah or just love
it right like yeah even for me I never
mastered mine what I was gonna do I
would just like love the game and I was
like I think I'll make the NBA you know
what it was for me is this I just
watched stand one yeah that's really
what it was like same that's really what
it what it was nobody plays basketball
Merced
maybe soccer where's that Merced Merced
is by Fresno okay okay before we get out
of here where can everybody find all
your content oh check me out the main
Hub well really all we are all platforms
the main one is Professor live YouTube
Professor live Tick Tock and Instagram
it's just the professor a professor live
Facebook too
um starting that YouTube membership up
probably if not we're on patreon for the
moment so be on the lookout for that how
do you get to page it's just the
professor on patreon Professor life
Professor yeah anything I do is gonna be
extension in the YouTube Just because
that's that's where your majority of the
traffic yeah that's what you send them
there and then they can just click the
links yeah but if you search Professor
Library the professors come up on Google
Twitter's the professor and your
clothing clothing Global hooper.com
check it out new drop actually coming
next two weeks so I'm really excited
about that that's nice man do you design
everything yourself I do actually I just
I had fun with it it's like it was like
started off as Hobby and really fun
like I'm trying to go big with it but
not knowing what's going big actually
entails like I learned a lot about the
clothing industry just obviously being
in sign to it I learned a lot but then
being in it you learn more so like start
off as hobby me my homies rocket
obviously some fans very few fan you
know you always sell less than one
percent of your audience right like
nobody really turns a buy unless they're
super invested that's true so uh start
out as a hobby but then it grew it's
like we sell out of drops like like it's
not like the culture's waiting on it but
I do actually want to try to make that
play you know what I'm saying like go go
big with it but it's globalcooper.com
it's it's the highest quality merch
brand you'll find nice dude literally on
the internet like it's you'll think it's
Supreme it's crazy good see that's
that's the way you have to kind of pitch
yourself and somebody gets and goes yeah
I love the professor more look at this
tag look at this that's why we try to do
but if somebody gets a hat and there's
threads hanging out you don't go damn I
hate New Era but if you get the
profession like you have someone to go
get pissed at now yeah you know so it's
yeah it's a small business only like
like it all works it all works but it
doesn't represent you I think like at
the end of the day though we're in the
merch era and even me like I'll buy a
I'll buy a shirt off a Redbubble or like
Walmart and I'll be like this lit all
right Amy Trey I know it itches and you
don't wash it right it's over but like
you don't really care because you're so
happy to rip whatever that old school
whatever that entity is true so like
think about it I ordered some of the
hottest Merch online like as a test I
was looking at like milk boys or
even Logan Paul right like I saw and I
ordered just just to see what that thing
was made that thing was trash but oh a
lot of people do that didn't matter are
you repping it for the love and it's
like t-shirts a t-shirt can't be that
bad you know what I'm saying so like oh
they can so respect to merch but if you
do come to Global who is going to be lit
like trust me
yeah the confidence and the passion
behind it like you said I just want to
see what it's like it's not even fake
though I've done that before yeah like
people say stuff online like they'll say
it's just like Supreme Nike Adidas and
like that's kind of gas like two tears
but I was like no I'm like like
literally I found some spend time
finding some great manufacturers who can
do it at a it's so hard discounted rate
yeah it's so hard yeah it's super hard
and you need seven figures like you do a
real brand like you need seven figures
it takes money man or yeah
600k yeah to pay your bills yeah and
they need a team you know you're trying
to do it for real for real like you need
a team you need to in-house a lot of it
you know stuff yeah you're not doing dgg
then right you're doing it all yourself
yeah we can say consider that insert
season but no it's in-house we don't do
ddg right now I don't like it it's a
money play and I'm not mad because you
don't spend a dime it's like
but but you know it doesn't have you
touch on it I feel like you're like oh
yeah 30 orders print them and make them
send them I never pre-sale it though not
ddg but like we'll pre-sale it so like
that's different here's the mock here we
make a real sound completely different
five cents most people do that and then
like you know you might get in a week or
two but like it is what it is like
people probably want it overnight and
we've done it we used to do it like that
our thing was crazy but it's like yeah
you lose money too it's like you're
keeping that inventory it's like man we
could have we could have sold out of
this two more times 16 Smalls I know
what he bought no I know you're you're
paying bro I haven't called the
warehouse full of it yeah there's eight
red shirts left nobody bought the red no
and then when you first get in you just
think it's lit to have a warehouse right
you like real small balls
headquarters oh I need one like on a
bike care about your head
that's what I did but starting to work
out so I get it so Global hooper.com
that's where everybody can find you yeah
yeah Marty thank you sir this was so
legendary me and my kid what other guest
is like my little eight-year-old so
stoked he's got to come up here at stock
designing for it thank you man we
appreciate it hey congrats on your guys
podcasts man I'm aspiring to get to
start a podcast too so I'm drawing
inspiration for seeing how you will you
guys did it from the ground up thank you
appreciate you guys having me I
appreciate it
thank you um anything else Marty no man
I just appreciate you being here when
you come back I'm excited to see what
other stuff you're gonna have you know
some year or whatever from now see
what's going on with all your different
businesses
um all your different videos and stuff
it's just inspiring thanks for pumping
those out man I mean like I said I watch
them my little brother walked he's 25
years younger than me that fool's on it
you gotta bring him next notifications
yeah oh dude he asked He Lives four
hours away Mike I don't know if I can
get you over here in four hours my bro I
know but my dad's ain't gonna do that I
already know he ain't gonna do it I
appreciate you being here thank you
thank you so much appreciate you guys um
so from Marty
Marty and I am from the professor guys
thank you so much for watching this has
been the dope as usual podcast have a
dope ass day
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie